David Hogg or David Hogg is he was a kid
a high school student from one of the
school shootings and he parlayed that
into a career as a left-wing activist
and he actually managed to get into
Harvard as a result of his notoriety
from his left-wing activism now David
Hogg I think is what 37 I don't know not
quite but he's an adult now and he
clearly has not been educated
he's been frozen in Amber as a petulant
child so he tweets out over the weekend
he says we need more artists and less
fascists
first of all
Harvard is no longer even teaching
people the difference between less and
fewer
should be fewer fascists it's a sort of
a side point
I usually don't pay attention to David
Hogg tweets but this one caught my
attention because you know anybody
slightly to the right of Barack Obama is
called a fascist these days
and the libs will they've accused me of
fascism I've got this debate tomorrow at
University of Pittsburgh oh by the way
there's an update on that the debate
that I was supposed to have at Pitt was
going to be with Professor McCloskey who
is a transgender identifying scholar
three degrees from Harvard half a dozen
honorary doctorates two dozen academic
Publications the very last minute he
pulled out
and he said it's because I'm
uninterested in the truth which is
obviously not true but even if even if
that were true Professor McCloskey has
been saying this about me for for over a
month now he's been saying I'm a fascist
well the usual arguments he's a fascist
he's he's uh not academically serious
he's this is just going to be a big show
but he had agreed on the importance of
the debate at the last minute he pulled
out and I think because he realized his
position was indefensible and he
realized that I wasn't going to call him
all sorts of nasty names and I wasn't
going to make a big scene I was just
going to I just intend to politely argue
my my point and so he realized there was
no win and he pulled out it would appear
to me out of cowardice I don't see any
other explanation so the update on that
is Brad Palumbo who is a Libertarian uh
commentator and he is not trans
identifying he's gay identifying so he's
he's somewhere around the rainbow
Spectrum uh he he is going to show up in
debate he won't he won't defend
McCloskey's full point Brad has adopted
more of a middle ground position on
transgenderism but the isi reached out
to I think a dozen leftists prominent
leftists that it felt would be good
debate partners for this issue none of
them agreed to come on and defend it so
we've got the second best option here
which is uh Brad will be defending
somewhat more moderate position but as
you know my view on transgenderism is
there can be no middle ground between a
man as a man or a man as can be a woman
so we'll be debating that and Professor
McCloskey can continue to call me a
fascist from his office hiding away from
from the debate David Hogg's point
though David Hogg says we need more
artists
and less fascists
what's so funny about this tweet
is that
David Hogg doesn't even know enough
about fascism to know that fascism was
an artistic movement
not just that fascism had something to
kind of do with with our art
the people who developed fascism were by
and large artists I'm thinking of
Gabriela denuncio the Italian poet I'm
thinking of Giuseppe ungaretti the
Italian poet I'm thinking of Felipe
marinetti the futurist artist who who
wrote one of the foundational texts a
two of the foundational texts of fascism
I'm thinking of Ubaldo OPI I'm thinking
about I'm I'm thinking of Carlo Cara I'm
thinking of the emergence of fascism out
of futurism
these people know so little about
fascism they don't they don't even know
who or what was involved in developing
it they probably don't know much about
futurism and and if they knew anything
about futurism if they knew anything
about the origins of fascism they would
know that modern conservatives don't
really fit that bill because futurism
was a movement that celebrated a
modernity it celebrated Machinery it's
celebrated speed the acceleration of the
development of culture things that
conservatives generally don't like
it's always silly when the libs throw
around their isms and you're this IST
and you're that ist and you're this
phobic and you're that phobic but
especially when it comes to Fascism is a
real movement
notice I'm not referring to a certain
Austrian painter I I suppose I could
throw him in there because German Nazism
was related to Fascism but they're
distinct movements Italian fascism is a
distinct movement it has a history if
any of these people
had the the courage to crack open the
cover of a book even once they could
learn about what fascism is but they
don't do that they don't care they don't
care about what we think they don't care
about what the fascists thought they
don't care about what anybody really
thinks all they don't care about reason
they don't care about intellect all they
care about is bludgeoning their
political opponents on the head and the
word fascism is a good tool for that
George Orwell wrote about this he said
fascism at this point basically just
means something I don't like
something I don't agree with so they'll
Club us on the head and they will
demonstrate their own ignorance now
speaking of political violence
there's a pro-life display
at University of Arizona pro-life
display with pictures of what abortion
looks like
it wasn't uh
particularly provocative other than it
showed the reality of abortion
but it didn't say here's what we should
do with abortionists it didn't say we
need to pass this law to Jail the
abortionists or anything like that
just said this is what abortion is
and the pro-abortion activists started
throwing eggs at the display they
started getting violent at the display
started mouthing off obviously at the
pro-lifers this video is provided by the
center for bioethical reform
[Music]
putting aside for a second
even the issue of abortion
if your first reaction
to Something in politics
is to let your emotions run away and to
become violent that's a good sign that
you are on the wrong side
the debate that we are having right now
at the highest level in politics is
about human nature human nature is
defined by two things
the fact that we have will and the fact
that we have intellect that's what
separates us from the animals and the
plants
and the rocks
we have Intel intellect we have a
rational soul
we can know things abstractly a pig can
know something about where to find food
but a pig doesn't think about Justice in
the abstract human beings uniquely among
the terrestrial created beings can do
that
so we have intellect and we have will we
can actually will to do something even
if it's contrary to our basist appetites
we've got will and intellect and the
purpose of education is to cultivate
your will such that it is in accord with
your intellect in accord with right
reason and in accord with reality
so on the one side of the debate you've
got will and intellect working together
which is what
serious philosophers and Statesmen for
all of history have wanted
then on the left side of the debate
you've got a vision of Will and
intellect being opposed to one another
you see this very clearly with
transgenderism
the intellect knows that boys and girls
are different the intellect knows that
if you're a man you've got the body of a
man that you're not really a woman
but the will you might have some
disordered desire to be a woman you
might have some disordered desire to
overcome the constraints of reality
and so in the left view when there when
there is some conflict between the will
and the intellect the will has to
overtake the intellect the disorder
desire has to reign supreme over what
you know to be true logically you see
this with abortion
with abortion the intellect knows that
the baby is a baby it's very difficult
to deny that the baby is a baby
but the will wants the license to murder
the baby if the baby is inconvenient
and so in the logic of abortion
the will has to reign supreme and
dominate what we know with our intellect
to be true this is why Naomi wolf in the
90s the feminist said
look we can all admit that the baby's a
baby but for women to have equal rights
the mother needs to be able to kill the
baby in all of his Humanity
this is why the libs when they're being
honest about abortion they'll make jokes
about babies they say yeah I'm going to
kill those babies
uh you bet I'm gonna kill those that
baby
this is
this is why the libs sometimes try to
make arguments that the baby isn't
really a baby but they can never make a
logical argument for it they just have
to invent new euphemisms so that's just
a clump of cells well you're a clump of
cells too what's the meaning of the
clump of cells no that it's just a
zygote well that's just a word you've
made up to refer to a little tiny human
being well it's just a fetus the fetus
is just a Latin word for Offspring well
that's just done uh I don't know what do
we run it let's can we make up a new
word can we make up a new word that
sounds like a Pokemon so that I can
ignore the fact that it's a baby that's
what they do but they don't make an
argument for it because it has nothing
to do with an argument it's purely about
Will
and there are plenty of societies in
history that have suppressed the
intellect suppressed reason and governed
not according to law a civil law and and
the reflection in the civil law of the
Eternal laws of Justice of the natural
law
there are societies that that just
are ruled by people clubbing their
opponents on the head
that's the society we're moving toward
as the libs gain power right now it's
music Monday Baby we've got to get to
the membrane segmentum
okay we have got to get to I'm finally
back in my studio I've got my trusty
iPad I will get to speak to you after a
week on the road last week where it was
a little hit or miss with the iPad and
we will be bringing to Bear our pop
culture hip-hop Maven skills to analyze
a new song this time
Mr Davies has given me a song
by Demi Lovato the show continues now
become a member of dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]